hey everybody what's going on back in
the geek culture studios for an
exclusive unboxing of marvel legends
what if brought to you by hasbro big
thanks to hasbro singapore for sending
over these uh figurines having said that
these are our thoughts and our thoughts
only
and um this is going to be fun now what
if is a new animated series on disney
plus for marvel studios and it kind of
flips the script on your favorite marvel
characters they change personas they
change characters completely it's
interesting anyway
in terms of the characters you're seeing
here today there is a build a figure uh
in this and it's the watcher now that is
the
bald headed guy that's all black right
now it's the beginning of each of the
episodes talking sort of narrating
everything that's going on we have two
build-a-figures from previous uh marvel
legends uh figures that we've gotten
here in the studio thanos and molten man
and we'll put together the watcher as
well so we'll show you all three so with
that
let's get down to unboxing our first
of our minifigurings here at geek
culture studios this video is brought to
you by logitech here at geek culture
gaming is a way of life and we always
enjoy dishing out headshots with
logitech g pro x super light mouse the
lightweight wireless mouse combines
excellent performance with classy no
frills look designed with pros and
engineered to win it offers crisp and
responsive clicks the smooth operator
even allows you to swap out the magnetic
dongle storage compartment for greater
gliding ease check out all of its other
features over at logitechg.com
okay let's start off with
my least favorite one sylvie sylvia
sylvie silvia
all right what do we got here anyway we
got uh silby's hands here
various different uh you know hands so
she can hold her
low-key sword we've got the loki sword
here
here's sylvie
i really don't i honestly zack i really
don't know about this character i i
didn't get silva you want to know why
sylvie was killing all these people the
very beginning of the series and all of
a sudden she became like loki's
girlfriend i'm like
how do we go from that to this anyway
let's talk about the design of the
character um in terms of
the face it does look a lot like the
actress i have to say i have to give
them that the detail is really nice
the various different tones of green
from the cloak then of course you have
her outfit there her combat boots i mean
it's a really nice character there now
you can take the cloak off her head
moves around so she can give you that
huh
look at that
look at that
so there we go
does she stand well on her own
she's a little bit
pigeon toed but she's okay
um a couple different hands if you want
to remove those put those on
you don't know how you do like this you
pull it out pull it out like that
put it in
so now she's got one hand that looks
like she wants to be wolverine and the
other hand's a fist
maybe that's a magic
you know so she can enchant people
then of course we've got her sword here
and uh yeah
interesting
i mean honestly speaking i don't think
anyone would probably buy this character
if it wasn't for getting the watchers
cloak but
yeah there she is
and that's pretty much it so
yeah that's sylvie
all right next let's move on to nebula
we're getting
parts of the watcher here so it looks
like we're getting the chest of the
watcher and also his waist
so
yeah
i guess you gotta pop that in there and
so now it looks kind of like a mannequin
right the watch is like a bit like a
mannequin right there exactly
let's look at
nebula
now i gotta say i love what they did
with nebula
um
and uh you know with the blonde hair
she's looking really sexy there's this
blue piece here i don't know what this
is for what's oh
like maleficent
all right so moving on to nebula here of
course gun in her hand right there uh
with the blonde hair she's looking good
i have to see the detail on this
figurine like all the figurines is
really really nice i mean the paintwork
the detail
her face
the sculpt really good i mean these are
always collectible uh collectors these
are obviously collectors figurines so
they're gonna have a much higher quality
than just some random mil you know
figure that you're gonna get into a toy
store so in that regard it's really good
of course the gun does fit in your
holster so if you want to put it there
you can you can short and you can change
the hands out so you can change the
hands on all these figurines even with
the silvia the same thing
standing up
uh it's not the easiest to pose to be
frank with you i mean you're really
gonna have to play around with it to
because the balance seems a little be a
little bit off the legs are really thin
and the top has a little bit more weight
so it's a bit challenging in that regard
but i have to say i mean it's a really
good looking figure
uh
yeah
she's beautiful i mean karen gill was
beautiful anyway i want to talk about
one of my favorite characters thus far
out of the three episodes funny enough
is captain carter i mean haley atwell is
fantastic as you know uh captain carter
in this i mean her voice works uh you
know the animators did really well with
captain carter i love the dynamic
between her and steve rogers it just
worked really well for me and the fight
sequences were fantastic as a matter of
fact you're kind of like man i think we
incorporated some of those in the movies
wow this really looks like haley atwell
this is a beautiful figurine guys
this is beautiful um
feels very substantial i have to say you
know
nebula felt a little bit thin a little
bit flexy you know sylvie okay not bad
but i have to say this one feels really
good she was beef here in the show
you're right she was yoked man when she
got out of that uh chamber right whoa
man she was jacked now there are no
extra hands with captain carter on this
so unlike the other characters where
they have a different hands you just
have one hand here and i'm guessing this
is where the shield goes and you
actually if you look in the back of the
shield you have these uh plastic
loops so there it is look at that dude
zacky how cool does that look
honestly
seriously right now out of the three
figures i've just opened up this is my
favorite no i actually liked i liked
what they did with this character out of
all the three what if stories thus far i
thought this was the strongest so uh
yeah this is cool man i like it okay
captain carter all right so now moving
on to uh
a character that is beloved by many and
his last performance in a marvel
cinematic uh universe
uh show of course is chadwick boseman as
t'challa star-lord
now inside of this we've got the
watcher's head
because
it's about time we get his head right
we need his head
he's not the best looking guy on the
planet i'll tell you that whoops
i guess he had a i guess i had an issue
with that statement
so this is the head of the watcher right
here uh
nice sculpt you know
larger head
humanoid these characters from the jack
kirby era of the 60s marvel comics are
some people like this and some people
don't personally this is what wasn't
what i grew up with but
this is going to be part of the marvel
cinematic universe going forward i think
for some time so
get used to the watcher folks he's going
to be around we'll put that head on
first and then we'll get to t'challa
ah now there goes the arm off yeah
see there goes these pieces off see this
is the downside with this but this is
figuring in my personal opinion this
piece does not stick on the back well at
all
at all
you push it in but it comes off very
easy the same with this arm here
so uh
yeah
once you get them together don't move
them around
which is sad because thanos right here
is really well put together i have to
say thanos is really well done uh molten
man is seems to be pretty solid um
the watcher
not so much first impressions
the face sculpt
doesn't really look like black panther
doesn't look like chadwick boseman it's
a little off
he looks more like uh
yeah he looks more like shaft than he
looks like you know t'challa you do get
some of those wakanda designs in the
jacket which is kind of nice
but you're not getting that um
that sculpt like i mean like with haley
outwell with captain carter with the
nebula even with sylvie this sculpt was
really good on the faces
this one is just
neither here nor there okay now the
jacket does not come off but you can
kind of
kind of spread it out a little bit here
you know and
he does come with his two guns
his two blasters there are no change of
hands on this
you know it is articulating but the knee
joints are a little bit tight again i
don't feel this is as solid as captain
carter in terms of figurine
um it does feel a little bit off
now i'm looking forward to this episode
so i'm thinking spider-man is gonna hunt
zombie captain america that's my
thoughts on it we got the spider-man
cloak here because this is zombie hunter
spidey how cool is that man
spider-man
okay
this looks nothing like tom holland at
all
this looks more like vanilla ice
look at that hairdo man look at the
pompadour on that man i'm jealous that's
that's some hair look at that hair zacky
it's almost like i mean obviously this
is the animated so we haven't seen the
animated show right so there's gonna be
some creative licensing on this so this
is not gonna be an exact
look but
it doesn't look like holland at all man
you know okay let's talk about the
spidey suit because this is interesting
spider-man suits are always a topic of
hot conversation the blue is a little
bit on the lighter side for me i like
the darker blue and the spider-man
outfit but i'm going to say the sculpt
is really nice you got to see the nice
separation between the deltoids and to
the biceps triceps the forearms you've
got these uh i guess web slinger
gauntlets here um the spider on the
front in the back is a little bit more
modern-esque you know he's a bit more
muscular looks like spidey's been uh
working out you know he's hunting
zombies he's got to be a little bit more
beefy right
yeah exactly
get to the gym do it he's probably
working with schwarzenegger the
terminator no he looks pretty good i
have to say but it's not like a
not a spider-man that we're used to
seeing from the movies thus far so it's
almost like he is inspired by doctor
strange a little bit you know what i
mean he could be
that's like a younger doctor strange
minus the white and the hair that's his
he's he's he's ripping off
dr strange's look right there here's
spidey's head and he's got hands as well
in there too
which are taped in
so
let's uh let's remove
peter's head
let's put spidey's head on there
looking at it now if i'm looking at if
i'm unless i could compare red to red i
think the red on captain carter is a
much better paint than what i'm seeing
here this is like
spider-man washed his suit too many
times you know and put in the dryer and
it's like faded like he needs to use
color guard it is right the cape's off
dude the cape's off
but again we don't know why we've got
the cape we haven't seen the episode yet
there could be a valid reason why he's
got the cape maybe maybe this is
dr strange's cape that's helping him out
speaking of doctor strange here we go
this is doctor strange supreme wow he
looks mean that's got a mephisto look to
that one right there that is a lot going
on first impressions in terms of detail
a plus
detail on this figurine is
nice
really well done
watchers of the leg as i mentioned
before
it's a bit tough to put on
put it to the side don't worry about it
okay
now
we've got some cool accessories here
because
dr strange uses his hands to conjure up
magic we've got one of his uh his
glowing discs with one hand here it's
kind of attached to that
quite cool
let's uh take out
the cape
so this is uh
dr strange supreme's new cape
it's got purple on the inside with nice
gold trimming then on the back of this
nice matte black
it's sort of and it's got a look at the
cowl look at the kawazaki the cow's
legit
the gold trim is really nice and there's
detail throughout the gold trim so
there's a lot of detail on this and
you're seeing these uh
the circular design that's on the back
it's also carried over into the inside
of it
very well done a plus to hasbro for the
details you could tell the creators
liked making this character more than
some of the others you know everyone's
got their favorite all right let's get
the cape on so actually there's a hole
in the back and there's this little um
pin here that you want to get the cape
and now this is a little bit challenging
because
this is not a uh
you're gonna kind of fold the cape back
like that and really push it in
and
yeah
there we go
the cape doesn't really
it's not really solid in there i mean
just again i think some of the fitment
on these characters
isn't the best out there in terms of the
plugs in terms of you know making sure
they're secure so that is something to
keep in mind again these are more for
display purposes only and that's pretty
much it i mean i can change his hand if
you want to show that uh the disc out
looks pretty dope man it's pretty cool i
mean it's a different take on doctor
strange and now
to our final figurine here
and this is uh i think everybody here
geek culture can say that this is our
favorite in terms of design we have not
seen the episode yet hopefully it'll be
coming soon this is zombie captain
america
wow this sculpt is
wicked
this is a cool sculpt
i'm loving this
saving the best for last you know what i
mean
okay we got the captain america shield
same design as we saw on captain carter
where the arm's gonna go through that
and uh
there's no additional hands with a
zombie captain america
but let's just talk about how nice the
sculpt is the amount of detail
from the rib
cage as you're seeing here the shredded
suit he's got one arm you know missing
for a clock like the watcher here look
at that the twins
he's also got half a leg so it's almost
like thriller
captain america you know like michael
jackson thriller
you know
yeah like that he could be in that music
video you know uh the helmet looks great
you can see the mouth the inside you can
even see there's holes in the cheekbones
right here you can see where it just
kind of spreads like it's just kind of
like open here and you can see that even
through his legs
this is legit
i think this could be
the star of this entire figurine series
right here in terms of uh
build and in terms of design
this is
a home run
a plus
captain carter was number one for me
very closely with doctor strange
zombie captain america takes it this is
badass
absolutely badass love it captain
america's shield the red the blue the
silver it feels like it's just got like
one layer of paint where they could have
kind of done a double coating on it give
it a little bit more richness still give
it that weathered look to it but at the
same time make sure the colors pop
it's just not there but i guess when you
look at it as a figurine as a whole it
does sort of match the faded red here
but i mean it's just a really nice
sculpt this is
a home run
this is cool it's freaky it's gonna give
you nightmares if you're don't like this
kind of stuff
but i have to say with the gold star on
this front here
the harness
man
they knocked it out of the park
those are the what if characters
from marvel legends uh the hasbro
figurines so once again big thanks to
hasbro singapore for sending these out
to us do check out the what if series on
disney plus um let us know what you
think of it are you a big fan of it or a
little bit unsure like myself and zacky
i would love to hear from you guys and
with that stay safe follow us on
facebook like this video helps us out a
lot subscribe to the channel and we'll
chat in the next one take care
[Music]
you